e se não fosse mesmo tendo assinado já
sei qual é por falar em mim
[Música]
a gente chama de mãe
ai ai ai não lê o que vimos no início é
são as primeiras experiências à série a
do cinema sonoro e curiosamente pra nós
comunicado é falar é trocada palavras
cantadas
enfim nós passamos mensagens através da
palavra só quanto o cinema nacional
chega a indústria já tinham passado mais
ou menos trinta e tal anos desde que se
estamos indo ou seja nos anos anteriores
três décadas antes comunicavam sem
palavra a palavra dita havia o centro
tempo no meio dos filmes para tentar
explicar um caminho mas a grande magia
os grandes realizadores eram aqueles que
conseguiram comunicar sem ter
necessidade de usar a palavra escrita
porque é falar da visita não se podia
tecnicamente colocar nos filmes que
tentavam contato e o cinema tenha
começado precisamente mudou do bando era
muito curiosa e
e é uma é uma é um é o segredo da gé da
indústria ao cinema dos treinadores que
efetivamente em 1900 em paris na
exposição mundial de 1900
já os franceses do as romã opinião
experimentar fazer filmes chamados e
conseguiram titular no campeão de frança
é um teledisco nós poderíamos chamado um
teledisco do videoclipe de uma cantora
muito conhecida na altura que cantava ou
vias ea imagem estava 5 de qualquer um
curiosamente foi preciso esperar por 30
anos para as pessoas começarem comunicar
com as primeiras experiências são muito
movimentados 1925 1964 mas só em 27 que
o cinema começa a ser falado e dizemos
há pouco maio maio é mês uma renda
porque o microfone não dava é que eu
gosto de comunicar gosto de partilhar as
minhas empresas porque sempre que nós
partilhamos algumas presenças sempre
comunicarmos com alguém
estamos também aprender estamos a
aperfeiçoar a nossa forma de comunicar
estamos a chegar às pessoas efetivamente
nós vivemos no mundo de grande
comunicação
vivemos no mar numa orgia comunicacional
intensa permanentemente mas é verdade
comunicamos muito aquilo que deve ser
maior parte mais importante a
comunicação porque os afectos que é a
comunicação até da dádiva comunicação de
chegarmos as pessoas vão pensar em peças
um exercício e vocês a partir de hoje já
vou ver isso até com crianças da frança
é para quem tem tem ver televisão os
canais de informação bastante entre os
canais de inflação que vim sem sol ou
seja não distingue os apresentadores os
piores notícias porque estes são os
mesmos a forma de acção é mesmo a forma
de escrever é mesmo
e isso mas se fica a comunicação à
distância das pessoas e ficar com o fat
é isso que faz a grande diferença porque
será que nós quando vamos ao filme com
determinado a todos sentimos uma
aproximação muito mais
olha aquela aquela personagem aquela a a
aquela interpretação do que se fosse
outro por exemplo imagine uma coisa
curiosa imaginem o indiana jones
o edno falta até ouvir começaram filmado
não era o action for câncer o ator era
fazer topless ela conseguiu com arlan
empreiteiro kombi balanceamento agora
estava na altura fazer uma série chamada
magno e e andou tentaram atentar a
tentar que quem deixar sem que deixassem
de fazer um indiana jones
não por intenção dos pelo george lucas
mas posto diz aqui eu tenho um contrato
para fazer essa série e os estudos não
dispensaram então qual foi a solução
para lançar o plano b plano b rs informa
euros e fornecê los tal maneira aquela
personagem aquela aquela aquela figura
que criou que nós não conseguimos
imaginar o o oe nela jones em web
informa que há anos é se não seria
melhor porque eu tenho carisma frente
tudo porque tem dá aquela personagem não
na uma representação ao bate tudo ok o
papel ea sua visão não eu entro anel
outras empresas criadas por exemplo casa
blanca toda a gente viu alto - mesmo que
não viram ou ouviram falar
é curioso que é daqueles filmes que
metade das suas crises em que viram
ouviram é e sabem o que é
pelo menos tem uma cena na cabeça aquela
cena do bairro do rei que sabiam que o
ator tinha sido escolhido pra que é o
papel e vencer quando foi bom ver que
não poderia ser outro o filme não ficava
na história do cinema se não fosse o
revólver era o ronald reagan havia se
apresentado no dia de natal até o fim
era o ronaldo chega a ser foco porque
tinha por que escolheram que não tinha
outra solução não tem outra solução mas
eu tenho aqui tudo por esta personagem
que fazer a coisa completamente
diferente e para terem uma vaia o edson
forte era mais ou menos é um
desconhecido em áudio era carpinteiro de
ser ator year é carpinteiro archs a
favor
passou e e uma vez vai arranjar uma
janela da casa umas portas da casa de
george lucas e ter-lhe-á dentre país
está eu sou ator sapos no a trabalho
então tem que dizer rasgar a fazer essas
coisas e tal
palavra puxa palavra eu sair vou fazer
um filme branquinho senão não tem
experiência e se calhar até podemos
facilitar essa oportunidade eu vou e foi
fez o américa no américa em grafite e
fez depois os star wars e já com algumas
também uma figura secundária que também
tomou conta da personagem transformou
ante sol num personagem única trabalhe
carismática da história do cinema e
quando vai para para os testes do edson
do dow jones foi contratado não para
aparecer no filme foi estavam aflitos
enquanto a procura da atriz necessária
pra para o papel da câmara pretende pôr
se volta com ela e então fizeram um
castiga o site a atriz e contrataram
esse foco eram ocorrer a sua casa dos
copos a malta para fazer um papel do
dólar nas baixas atriz cepa
olha o papel dele existe aquilo que o
outro e eu havia raparigas todas a lei
até escolherem aquela é país pois no
final do ano mas com certeza absoluta
que não ia ser é o ator no filme eu sei
que o que passar por ali estava atrás da
câmera só dizer as falas do do suposto
das portas personagem porque já sabia
que o time se ela queria seria tudo isso
quer dizer que em tudo aquilo que nós
fazemos em tudo aquilo que nós
partilhamos na vila temos que ter
atitude temos ter vontade e determinação
há sempre muitas vezes a escolas
universidades a dar palestras e fazer
workshops com os jovens porque acho que
é também uma obrigação do que faz
comunicação é partilhar as suas
experiências para perceber que não é nem
tudo são rosas
a vida não é feita
hum só de sucesso atrás de sucesso há
sempre muitas muitas vicissitudes
os americanos têm uma expressão muito
engraçada que dizem que há uma série de
figuras do cinema canção resultados o
overnight sosa lã então se em causa essa
corda um famosos e alguns desses dessas
personagens carismáticas da história do
cinema
que crise pode fazer ou dizer a verdade
o sucesso é verdade que eu cortei famoso
ou não sabem nem as noites que não dormi
para chegar à lei e errado que por muito
que vocês lá iam das revistas cor de
rosa
por muito que percebam que é tudo muito
bonito e é tudo glamouroso e as três
ficam também há sempre por trás alguma
muito suave há muita isso é igual para
tudo é igual topava e dos companheiros
de física quântica como é a atitude
determinação ea vontade de superar é eu
eu eu
[Música]
agora sim e hoje a comunicação
nunca foi tão fácil mas também de alguma
maneira nunca nos afastou tanto dos
desafetos
eu comecei a praticar em bater melhor
porque hoje eu vou acordar amanhã em los
angeles é e caso embora mas às vezes há
20 a 29 anos ea confusão a 29 anos foi
ontem mas fazendo confusão eu ter um
trato com as pessoas e era andei para o
lado da mãe para o outro mas aquilo
acabava ali cada um vai para sua casa
não há cá convívio no placar
era tudo muito muito da língua mas
estranha porque precisávamos
aquelas pessoas ao israel nem para um
lado nem para o outro lado de button mas
acaba tudo a limpo
curiosamente passados estes anos todos
nós temos um caminho assim machado isso
nós nós europeus nós portugueses por
causa desta forma de comunicar esta
facilidade de comunicação
nós usamos este tema de uma forma
gratuita e não não pensava os neons
quando quantos exames
estamos a essa alma é uma caricatura da
situação mas na verdade nunca como dizia
há pouco nunca foi tão fácil comunicar
mas também nunca foi tão banal e sem
pensamento comunicado
e acho que a televisão os meios de
comunicação tradicionais
viemos aqui o ecommerce essas novidades
todas que o seu próximo
a verdade é que só vinga quem tem afeto
quem tem determinação quem tem atitude
para muitas coisas
e mesmo com 10
mesmo com os meus grandes feitos com
todos nós temos eu tô primeiramente eu
tento fez 30 anos duvidam
há 30 anos que o preço em casas todos e
todas as semanas desde o tempo que se
ouvia motorizado quando comecei a
trabalhar na televisão
se eu começar a xingar tarde melhor
havia um caminho para nova tábua e
depois a 68 acaba com o hino lembra os
mais novos devem ser pagos pra isso não
pode ser 30 anos foi ontem e hoje nós
temos 300 canais no carro
temos ou seja é fácil ir à linha
variedade também acaba por pôr nos criar
algum problema de comunicação
mas na verdade essa atitude eu acho que
é os mais jovens que a questão está a
partilha que eu aqui posso deixar posso
fazer é usar um caminho em relação
aquilo que vocês vão fazer por villa
principalmente para os mais novos é que
nunca desistam de lutar com o que querem
fazer porque o sonho fazer
imprudentemente de sonhos
é entrou por vários deitar forçando
estado 'tratava' la plata maneira de o
bio bío fazer o caminho de frente e de o
adaptar ocorre uma coisa muito engraçada
uma pra acreditar que posso fazer aqui e
confira essa é uma história que o que
aconteceu comigo
a primeira unidade para começar é eu
recebia eu acho que o único com muita
gente é porque eu visitei esta coisa é a
próxima
falsamente aproxima-nos e meu parto deus
no total para você já deve ter
acontecido eu não vou mostrar
autorizando o som são profissional
provisão estrelas são aquelas que várias
fraturas ao fim de semana e eu pretendo
a chuva elas dizem que gosta muito da
mulher e do marido dos filhos e ter
filhos lá em casa e depois passados 15
dias e preparar se você papel neutro
desgostou facebook e gravata que fez na
vida mas agora o que é certo é que é
essa atitude que nós vivemos num país
muito pequeno mesmo ou mesmo os ácaros
mulato ou uma grande estrela da
televisão portuguesa vai a tua e ninguém
liga nenhuma portanto isto é pequeno nós
somos 10 milhões a uma coisa engraçada
que eu aprendi com o ator no já clama da
crise é uma coisa deliciosa uma vez o
prontuário e eu fui um declínio entre
saiu duas vezes invisível e eu já morreu
há mais de 15 anos e eu entrevistei no
final da década da vida duas vezes e
adorava porque normalmente quando estou
mais velho tem muitas histórias pra
contar
já não tem nada para pra para provar a
ninguém está tão à vontade e eu e nunca
esquece uma coisa que duas pessoas que
já não estão cá me ensinaram uma
portuguesa e essa jackman que a câmara
deve ser pago como é que era nos anos 50
ser um sexy mul
ela não segue sem bola era uma figura no
tempo áureo cinema daquela coisa que era
só o amor ea cepa
especial ser uma venda ser uma estrela é
só porque eu vou explicar uma coisa você
é jovem
nunca esqueça de uma coisa que eu que
vou dizer que nunca mais esquece já foi
há mais de 15 anos
as ações da tam por cada pessoa que vai
bater nas costas e quase é fantástico
você assiste ao você é o seu incrível
simplicidade
olha volta e beneficiou os outros que o
calendário não ter que carregar um terço
ou mais dos que os que vai bater nas
costas e não dizem nada sobre os
empregados é e em lidar com a com estas
coisas é é sempre isto e dizia o queijo
que fez há muito que nós somos muito
poucos é e eu dizia que se comunicavam
pessoas no início bombeiros paulo para o
quarto 9 em maio via computadores há 30
anos atrás era coisa que ele mais
difícil ea coisa é uma coisa fantástica
que havia um jovem que tinha uma tirinha
aceitar escreveu muita gente pra
televisão e eu respondi responder a toda
a gente ainda tenta responder com
coragem ea dada altura queria estar
cinema e os pais será empatar logo
cinema que não dá nada não dá pra isso
vocês estão loucos mas fazer um curso de
direito concurso economia que o pai
fiquei a saber mais alguns anos depois
era médico deve ser de 4 concluir que só
tem só para fazer para convencer os seus
pais você aí que eu quero segue para o
caso
ambos dizem que se a professar não é
vida se não desista de se olhar seja
seis anos para taís que parece que sabe
isto quietos usados um curso que não tem
nada a ver
e depois há toda a vida um frustado com
eo paraguai mas eu quero ser presa e o
que acontece tem vai aprofundar o abismo
tac uma colega que ter uma comunicação
escrita o que alguns tempos maioria véus
ou 90 por cento querem ser estrelas
torres não crescer pivotal jornal
outros 10% gostam da net discretos e foi
dos pés mas a grande maioria quem querem
participar
quero ser o seu município ou no mínimo é
tanto assim
dodô dos padrões pré-definidos e tal
esse rapaz lá foi uma vez deve ter lido
a carta aos pais e lá os convenceu e foi
estudar para escolas presidência que é a
única que havia em portugal na altura
desapareceu do mapa nunca mais sobre ela
e eu disse para ela que receberam mas eu
vou fazer filme os olhos que isto vai
ser uma medalha é agora já concluído mas
concretizar o sonho mantém a mente
aberta para fazer outras coisas na área
senão eu quero quero frisar que tal já
fez curso desapareceu do mapa e nunca
mais o museu do chew entrou 17 18 19
anos universidade nunca mais o vi
passado oito anos trabalhava em um lance
que estava a fazer a pós produção do dom
do documentário que estava a fazer e
pedir para arranjarem um sonoplasta para
tratar do som porque eu queria por 11
faixas e umas coisas e até pai engajou
na hora paga vai um sonoplasta do outro
mundo
lá fui pra só na platéia tem uma penca
de trabalho noite só precisa ter um som
para o sol limpinho e vibrou ele será um
apoio parcial foi passado à noite
contrariado pa se posicionou e e eu
quero dizer o seguinte chegou a e taí o
o odioso que nunca tinha conhecido
pessoalmente eu vou eu sou um rapaz que
é pai do realizador não só na pasta
só digo é hoje grande muitos filmes
americanos mas não posso produzidos em
portugal é ter um só por esses jovens
não desistiu
outro dia estava a fazer uma palestra
trabalho e no final ver um jovem ter
comigo e disse olha você não está a
acontecer pois não é esse
sinceramente eu vou dizer uma coisa
sorriso do cinema de animação e por sua
causa
por minha causa sempre quando eu tinha 7
anos
eu vou eu andava da tropa ou favela da
capital levava o próprio ao meu lado e
eu falava que eu falava com tanto
entusiasmo e cinema de animação e punham
mil de auxiliar a meu lado no da
secretária e não faz assim passará a ter
um link para ver como é que fazem está
trabalhando no roteiro em
é em san francisco a desenvolver
animação digital e admiração isso aqui
tudo é essa eu soube que ele só queria
concluir que uma coisa não tem nada a
ver empregado na baixa entre os
opositores vão estar aqui hoje eu posso
mostrar a fotografia é que ela é esta
fotografia amigo na casa rosa minha
filha rita
a vida tem destas coisas às vezes
pagamos uma partida eu até achei a rita
é quase como aquela cena eu quero é pai
eu quero um carro
amerell de uma marca shishou tá que
nunca não há cá em portugal e portanto
vou encomendar um carro amarelo daquelas
amarelo luminosos que eu nunca vi no
âmbito galo quer ter um carro único no
dia em que eu saí do estado só ver os
carros daquela que é aquela coisa que a
vida também nos faz a rita tem
preservado e eu disse ver poucas na nato
todas as duas primeiras posições que eu
já tive o cuidado de inserir será que
nós estamos pretendendo falar com ela
a rita anita frazier rural e tem aquilo
que o que eu sei é a prova de que estou
aqui e 02 em prática não é só a padre
olha o que eu digo não olhes para o que
eu faço é hoje a confissão e depois de
vôo o futebol deixou novos ao árbitro
que nos ensina é isto que eu estou a
tentar passar em estava principalmente
jovens nunca se esquecem é e não
consegue encontrar a filha só pra acabar
e escrevi um texto eu gosto das ao
descrever as coisas que eu mais gosto de
fazer mas estou visando e então às vezes
escrevo coisas em parte lhe faço os
preços e já tem funcionado muito grande
com coisas que escrevi e esta é este
caso é curioso porque outro dia escrevi
o texto prossegue com esta falta
mandaram esta foto eu não estava nesse
espetáculo estava em londres a trabalhar
ea rita que tem a mania que estava sem
valor e nunca vai ser mas não deixa de
ter atitudes bailarina
então eu escrevi estatais comprou deixar
porque é porque eu sou aqui a minha
doença é a atitude que o fim das pessoas
é vontade que eles voltem transforma-as
hoje em credo é o sorriso cruzarmo
obstáculos que faz par com sites e
padrões de norma o que se vê nesta foto
de seu prédio no olhar mais atento é
contemplação do sonho partir do olhar
sereno da rita que adorava ser bailarina
na verdade ela já subiu mais vezes ao
palco para receber o aplauso qualquer
outro jovem de sua idade
a costura um olhar vida criam pomos
sempre respeito o objetivo ser fluir ser
capaz de ser ela mesma da sua condição
de frente sem complexos ou volta mesmo
com dor
basta querer o grupo sair nesta foto e
ela inspirou na verdade o clube desta
imagem este rio saiu de cadeira de rodas
é quando é difícil mudar a condição tudo
se altera mudando a atitude foto alegra
porque ao fazer o filme da vida da reta
ainda uma curta metragem é já uma grande
profissão o que quiser quando nos
cruzamos com gente que faz de um sopro
um vendaval de um espirro um dia ouvi
não sabem o que é o ano do instrutor da
vida
a rita provas todos os dias na sua
supressão o barulho e dizia que são 11
títulos e não as circunstâncias que
termina um valor cada um
dançar em pontas é apenas uma técnica
nem todos conseguem mais sorrir sem
complexos já todos podem
depois é só dizer mesmo que o baixinho a
menina dança e isso faz a poesia com os
e rodas designers as estrofes da vida
acima tudo aqui tudo é alavancado
introdutório da vida e que a copa
terminar
só pra concluir e o que eu leio as 10
porque porque eu escrevi o texto no
iphone inteira e é uma viagem e e
cruzando com fotografias que viu tais
pública e deixar mais ou menos 80 mil
contatos e tem uma particularidade
eu percebo o que vai cuidar 1 e da
tristeza das pessoas
o 'retorno' meu facebook tem quase 30
mil seguidores e percebe o quanto falta
d'afectos e tem toda a determinação que
existe na sociedade hoje a última frase
é outra outro recado fica para a vida é
e que ficou pra vida pra mim eu tenho
batido socorro r 500 mais velhos criança
eu tenho grato prazer trabalhar muitas
vezes com ela e que era miguel e éramos
muito amigos e o henrique tinha uma
coisa muito engraçada quando estava das
pessoas rezavam as pessoas e eu tive é
só ser humano um dos dos 2.000 da
profissão que cruzou cowell já no fim da
vida o véu
nasci e vivo e adorava o qual era mil na
televisão e o enriqueçam dizia uma coisa
que jamais esqueça de uma coisa é parar
nunca se leva a sério e faça as coisas
com muita seriedade e é isso que eu
tento fazer todos os dias com o título
confrontado e contribuição muito bom dia
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]